good morning John it's Monday January
15th I'm sitting in front of the new
Brotherhood 2.0 website you can find it
Brotherhood to calm appreciate any
suggestions or comments the podcast
isn't quite working but we'll get there
well I'm feeling better I'm not feeling
great now I've got this voice it's like
not so much of a voice it's just little
popping noises ah one of the advantages
is that I'm kind of a baritone now I
guess I'm usually a baritone but maybe
I'm a bass
maybe I'm a bass stuff do not forsake me
though you know I must burn so I went to
Barnes and Noble yesterday I had to walk
up for the lady at the desk because I
didn't know where they would keep this
book and I had to say I'm looking for a
book it's called we wish to inform you
that tomorrow we will be killed with our
families and she said that's catchy so I
brought the book home and then something
interesting happened
so yeah it didn't happen
I'm not saying that the Brotherhood 2.0
book club is not a good idea I'm just
saying that right now I'm going to have
to avoid your genocide book for a little
while and when I say a little while I
mean like less than a week so we'll
probably started for Brotherhood 2.0
Friday Brotherhood 2.0 agreement moment
that's right
John and I agreed on something I think
it's a great idea for us to do our happy
dances for three minutes and 30 seconds
that sounds like a perfect Brotherhood
2.0 project idea I don't have Daniel
Biss but I do have this it's the
University of Montana gave me for all of
my hard work 3.5 minutes times 60
seconds in a minute / 5 seconds per clip
is 42 now there are several amazing
things about this idea first is that you
got the math really very wrong
the second remarkable thing about this
idea is that Daniel Biss commented
within like three seconds of you posting
the video told you that you were wrong
must be very convenient to have your own
personal mathematician I gotta get me
one of those last and most remarkable
about this idea is that we now know the
question what are you talking about
oh sorry well the answer to the question
of life the universe and everything is
42 right so question must be how many
happy dance clips does it take to fill
up a brotherhood 2.0 segment we really
are doing some amazing things here I've
been very impressed by the number and
quality of this printed business card
utilization ideas thank you very much I
will be discussing those and other
sundries on Wednesday John I'll see you
tomorrow